we were talking about death in the
beginning okay i don't really i'm not
afraid of death is that weird nope i
thought you don't think about it
so it's it's not it's not like a common
but it's not you're not the only one
there's a study on death that basically
faces people with their death and we see
that many people shut down part of their
brain when they see what they did is
they basically show you a picture and
then at some point they flash a picture
of you being buried just like this and
people's brain must be shut down they
couldn't take it however there was a
group of people about 10 who totally
kind of they saw pictures and they saw
their own death and it was another
picture so you know among 10 percent not
zero but then again at the same time i
do believe the um is it ernest becker
the uh book the worm at the core about
terror management theory that like
basically everything we do is just to
manage our terror because we know we're
going to die like just the way that we
like distract ourselves the way that we
need accolades and awards and and family
shields like the way that we have to
like make ourselves um
uh like immortalize ourselves with
trophies and shit so here's the good
part ready 2019 just before the panemic
the study comes out that shows that we
can now start playing with death and
maybe prolong life a bit after you die
so here's what they did in the study
this is a nature 2019 i'm pretty sure
does anyone look at the news now like i
want to live longer
but it's just a weird time to want to
live longer there's a this community is
after me all the time like i get emails
from them daily people who have a you
know okay how can i
replace my body and stay longer then i
get i got yeah yeah yeah yeah
the people who want to live longer
they're they really want neuroscientists
to help them yeah so the study looked
like that they took a pig it was a pigs
took pigs that was slaughtered in a
slaughterhouse at let's say noon so the
pig is dead at noon and what they do as
soon as the pig is dead they extract the
brain and put it in a basically
incubator they feed it with nutrients
they use circulated blood they kept the
brains
of the pigs alive and the pig is already
dead
and what they showed instead is that not
only can you keep the brain active in
thinking for hours in this case after
the pig is dead but also that you can
actually extract information you can
actually kind of zap out of a brain and
it responds if you want so you can
essentially communicate with the dead
pig's brain after it's dead
so you can imagine
us doing a trust with humans so you know
you die at noon and we basically take
the bodies okay whitney version one is
dead but in the tube here in the
aquarium we have whitney still with us
but will the brain be like i'm fucking
dead what the fuck why'd you do that
that's funny like i didn't have a good
day he doesn't know who you're the
body's dead so
i feel like there's no not gonna be a
lot of conversation that's not about
like what the fuck i'm bad why are you
asking me it like maybe people look at
me
like the brain knows yeah it was dead
yeah i mean who knows it's big but like
totally talking about it fucking kill
the rest of me fuck this i cannot see
that being like a normal useful thing
like grandma's the same conversation
why didn't you stop me from dying why
the fuck are you asking me all these
questions
where were you when i had the gun
yeah exactly yeah that's
i
i watched this documentary about life
after death and one of the big
arguments for that something exists
after death was that someone could die
on an operating table and there'd be
absolutely no brain activity but they'd
be aware of something happening in the
room so i guess that means that's just
i mean so so clear this only pigs only
one study this is all now kind of what
we can do but it made scientists really
start imagining like okay like can we
you know imagine actual commerce book
like you you go and you find a dead body
and you kind of instead of saying like
let's find who it is you ask the body
like who killed you the butler thank you
let's go there's like a this is like the
shell accounts
or you know someone dies and you say who
do you want the money to go to right
like you didn't write a wheel we can ask
you so there's some kind of
nice thing about it right now the the
most the coolest and weirdest
thing that people play with is using
people's brain so to speak for tasks you
basically have the brain do chores for
you so you kind of i mean the cells are
really boring but like you basically
there's a there's a task that a lot of
people are carrying interested in which
is uh classifying images even in death
you'll be working
i mean if you guys make my
dead brain or live brain we're going to
sort images
i swear to fucking guys dog cat cat dog
that's it and is that what like
billionaires are just gonna have like
nine brains like just in their house
like working for them
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]